ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES
BELL OR JUST BRADFORD CABALLERO
CHIANG DOW. DODD THE ROSTER
GALGIANI GLAZER GONZALEZ GROWTH
HERTZBERG HILL HUESO TADO
JACKSON JONES LEYVA MCGUIRE
MITCHELL MON MORE LAW MORALE
NIELSEN PAN PORTS. RAW RUBIO
SKINNER STERN AMBERG LIKE HOW
STEVE WIENER WELL. COLLEAGUES A
CORE IS. WITH THE MEN AND GUEST
BE THE RAY. AND IN THE PLEASE
RISE WE WILL BE. INTO TODAY BY
OUR CHAP SISTER MICHELLE
GOURMET AFTER PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING AS WE WILL BE LED IN
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO OUR
FLAG BY SENATOR BAIL. LET US BE
CENTERED IN GOD'S PRESENCE
AGAIN. WE PRAY TODAY IN THE
WORDS OF MAYA ANGELOU. FATHER
MOTHER GODS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENCE DURING THE HARD AND
MEAN DAYS FOR THEN WE HAVE YOU
TO LEAN UPON. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENCE DURING THE BRIGHT
AND SUNNY DAYS. FOR THEN WE CN
SHARE BASS WHICH WE HAVE WITH
THOSE WHO HAVE LESS. AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENCE DURING
THE HOLY DAYS. FOR THEN WE'RE
ABLE TO CELEBRATE YOU AND OUR
FAMILIES AND OUR FRIENDS. FOR
THOSE WHO HAVE NO VOICE WE ASK
YOU TO SPEAK. FOR THOSE WHO
FEEL UNWORTHY WE ASK YOU TO
POUR OUT YOUR LOVE IN WATER
FALLS OF TENDERNESS. FOR THOSE
WHO LIVE IN PAYING WEASK YOU
TO BEG THEM IN THE RIVER OF
YOUR HEALING. FOR THOSE WHO ARE
LONELY WE ASK YOU TO KEEP THEM
COMPANY. AND FOR THOSE WHO ARE
DEPRESSED WE ASK YOU TO
SHARAPOVA IN THEM THE LIGHTS OF
HOPE. DEAR CREATOR USED THE
BORDERLESS CITY OF SUBSTANCE WE
ASK YOU TO GIVE TO ALL THE
WORLD'S BEST WHICH WE NEED MOST
HE'S A MAN. REPEAT AFTER ME I
PLEDGE. TO THE FLAG. A FORMER
AS TO FOR WHICH HE- ONE NATION
INTO THE- WITH YEAH FOR ALL.
GOOD CALL. WE WILL PROCEED WITH
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR OF
WHICH THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES
FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL BE
DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES ARE
THERE ANY OTHER MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS OR NOTICES. SEEING
NONE. AT THIS POINT I WOULD
LIKE TO TAKE A POINT OF
PERSONAL PRIVILEGE TO INTRODUCE
ONE OF THE HEROES OF MY COUNTY
AFTER OUR DEBRIS FLOW. HE
PULLED TOGETHER FIVE PEOPLE WHO
CREATED THE BUCKET BRIGADE AND
AS VOLUNTEERS THEY BAILED OUT.
HUNDREDS OR THOUSANDS OF
RESIDENTS WHO ARE MIRED IN SIX
TEN TWELVE FEET OF MUD.
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE CAME
TOGETHER AND A ONE OF THE
LEADERS OF THIS EFFORT BOTH FOR
THE OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY AND NOW
STATEWIDE TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
READY FOR EMERGENCIES I'D LIKE
TO INTRODUCE IT'S MY HONOR AND
PRIVILEGE TO INTRODUCE MY
FRIEND A POWELL WHO IS HERE
WITH US THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBERS THANK YOU EIGHT FOR
EVERYTHING. MOVING ALONG TO
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED
READ REPORTS OF COMMITTEE. I'M
SORRY WE'VE ALREADY DONE THAT.
INTRODUCTION AND FIRST READING
OF BILLS IS THE NEXT ITEM MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL. EIGHT SEVENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY ONE EIGHT SEVENTY TWO
AND SENATE BILL EIGHT SEVENTY
THREE. THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY UNDER CONSIDERATIONS
OF THE DAILY FILE UNDER
UNFINISHED BUSINESS WE HAVE
FILE ITEM FOR. FILE ITEM FOR
THE SENATOR BRADFORD. DO YOU
WISH TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM FOR.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
THIRTY ONE BY SENATOR BRADFORD
RELATIVE TO THE WILLIE L. BROWN
JUNIOR CIRCLE AND FOSSA SENATOR
BRADFORD THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT IN
MEMBERS- ESSIE OUR THIRTY FOURS
BACKING CONCURRENT WOULD
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS THIS REP
RESOLUTION SIMPLY LOOKS TO
HONOR FORMER SPEAKER WILLIE I.
L. BROWN AND FORMER MAYOR OF
SAN FRANCISCO FOR ALL THE
TREMENDOUS WORK THAT HE HAS
DONE- FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IT'S A SEEKS TO.
RENAME THE PUBLIC CIRCLE- AND
PLAZA AT NINE FOURTEEN NINE
FIFTEEN CAPITAL MALL AS WILLIE
L. BROWN JUNIOR CIRCLE AND
PLAZA IT CELEBRATES AGAIN THE
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT HE HAS MADE
BOTH LEGISLATIVELY PERSONALLY
AND HISTORICALLY TO THE STATE
AND HIS UNRELENTING DEDICATION
TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
RESPECT LAST RAGO. THANK YOU
CENTER BRADFORD TURNING TO OR
DISCUSS ON THIS ITEM ANY DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION. SEEING AND
HEARING NON MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS FIVE BASEI
FELL I FOR JUST FIVE BRADFORD I
HAVE A- I CHIANG. DALLY AYE
DODD HI THERE ARE SO FIVE
GALGIANI I GLAZER HI GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. HERTZBERG I HILL I
HUESO. HI TADO FIVE JACKSON I
JONES FIVE LEYVA. I MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL FIVE MONNING FIVE MORE
LOCK I MORRELL. I NIELSEN I PAN
AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH I RUBIO
HI SKINNER I STERN I UMBERG I
LIKE HOW SKI HI WIENER AYE WILK.
FIVE I THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING ALONG TO SENATE THIRD
READING WE WILL START WITH FILE
ITEM SIX. BY SENATOR BRADFORD.
SAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION TEN BY
SENATOR BRADFORD RELATIVE TO
CANNABIS SENATOR BRADFORD THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AS J. R.
TEN CALLS FOR CONGRESS AND THE
PRESIDENT THE UNITED STATES TO
AN ACT LEGISLATION WHICH WOULD
REMOVE CANNABIS FROM THE
FEDERAL DRUG SCHEDULES UNDER
CURRENT LAW CANNABIS REMAINS A
SCHEDULE ONE ALONG WITH OTHER
DRUGS SUCH AS HEROIN LSD-
PERPETUITY AND- ALL. THE OTHER
HORRIBLE COULD ON FIT A MEANS
THE EXIST OUT THERE. OTHER
CURRENT SYSTEM SIR SERIOUSLY
FLAWED AND IN POLLS AND IF
BEARSTED. CANNABIS INDUSTRY
CANNABIS HAS PUT TO FOR BI<c.cyan>.</c>
ESTABLISHED MEDICAL YOU AND
IT'S ROLE OF TO OTHER SUBS
LISTED ON THE FEDERAL DRUG
SCHEDULE IT WILL EVEN WHEN WE
MADE IT ILLEGAL IN THE FORTIES-
THE AMERICAN MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION WAS ADAMANTLY
OPPOSED TO ADDING IT AS A
SCHEDULE ONE REMOVING KADAM IS
FROM THE DRUG SCHEDULE WOULD
ALLOW. RESEARCH FACILITIES TO
DO REGULAR RESEARCH AS WE'VE
SEEN IN ISRAEL- TO SHOW THE
BENEFITS AND HELP. ENSURE
ACCRUING SUCCESSFUL INDUSTRY
FOR OUR STATE IT'S TIME FOR OUR
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO STEP ODD
TO BE IN STEP WITH THE MULTIPLE
STATES ACROSS THIS COUNTRY AND
REMOVE IT AS A SCHEDULE ONE ARE
TYPICALLY UP FOR A VOTE. THE OR
DISCUSS N THIS ITEM DEBATE
DISCUSS SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THE
VOTERS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. ON MORE THAN ONE
OCCASION HAVE OFFERED THEIR
OPINION WITH RESPECT TO
SCHEDULE MARIJUANA AS A
SCHEDULE ONE DRUG. THE VOTERS
HAVE DECIDED THAT FOR PURPOSES
OF STATE A CALIFORNIA MARIJUANA
IS LEGAL. BUT THERE IS A
MECHANICAL PROBLEM AS IT
RELATES TO. THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WE HERE TRY TO
PROTECT OUR PUBLIC SAFETY THE
ASSISTANT MAJORITY LEADER TELLS
ME STORIES OF TWO BILLION
DOLLARS BURIED IN BARRELS AND
COMMUNITIES THAT HE REPRESENTS.
WE HAVE ALL SORTS OF STORIES
READ OUR NEWSPAPERS AS THE
AWFUL BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA
ARE TRYING TO ENGAGE IN THEIR
RESPECTIVE ACTIVITY AND YET
BECAUSE- OUR MARIJUANA REMAINS
A SCHEDULE ONE DRUG THE FEDERAL
BANKING SYSTEM CANNOT TAKE THAT
MONEY. AND WE HAVE A VERY
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM IN THAT
REGARD ALSO WITH RESPECT TO
COLLECTING TAXES AND HAVING
EXTRA COSTS THAT ARE
EXTRAORDINARY TO THE GOVERNMENT
IN PROVIDING SECURITY AND C. H.
P. TAKE A AT PROVIDING THE
ESCORT SERVICES TO PROVIDE CASH
TO GO TO THE BANK SIX GREATEST
SIGNIFICANT MANAGEMENT PROBLEM
ONE OF THE ONE HAND THE VOTERS.
CITY CAL WE HAVE MADE TERMINATE
THAT THIS IS  SOMETHING THIS
LAWFUL AND LEGAL AND THERE EYES
THE GENERAL IS IN FOR WOULD
WITH THE UP. TO PROVIDING
PUBLIC SAFETY I STAND HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO GET THIS
OFF OUR BACKS SO THAT THE
PEOPLE'S WISHES CAN BE TAKEN
CARE OF AND WE CAN SAFELY BANK.
OF REVENUE FROM THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR THANK YOU MADAM CENTER
X. QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR WE
ACCEPT THE C<c.cyan> YES THANK YOU.</c>
BY GOOD FRIENDS ANGELES I
CERTAINLY. AND AGREE WITH YOU
THAT WE SHOULD REMOVE MARIJUANA
FROM SCHEDULE ONE I JUST WANT
TO CLARIFY THAT THE RESOLUTION
IS JUST AS WE SAID REMOVE FROM
THE SCHEDULES WE'RE JUST
CALLING FOR REMOVING IT FROM
SCHEDULE ONE EIGHT BECAUSE
AFTER ALL THERE'S MANY OTHER
THEIR SCHEDULE TWO THREE FOUR.
AND WE CAN DEBATE WE WON'T
DEBATE AS TO WHERE WHICH NUMBER
SHOULD HAVE BUT IT SHOULD BE
JUST BUT PARTICULARLY THIS
RESOLUTION IS FOCUSED ON
REMOVING IT FROM SCHEDULE ONE
WHICH I AGREE WITH YOU IS AN
APPROPRIATE. YES I OVER
FOCUSING ON SCHEDULE ONE BUT IF
YOU WANNA ASK MY PERSONAL
OPINION IS SHOULD BE REMOVED.
FROM ALL SCHEDULES. OKAY WELL.
WE WILL DEBATE THAT ISSUE I
JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY THE-
RESOLUTION A WHAT WE'RE CALLING
FROM THE RESOLUTION- CERTAINLY
IF THE RESOLUTION- CALLS FOR
SIMPLY REMOVING IT FROM
SCHEDULE ONE- I WOULD- TONIGHT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
CENTER BRADFORD WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE ON THE ITEM YES THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU
MEMBERS IN THANK YOU MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO FOR
THAT QUESTION- I. IF WE KNOW
HISTORICALLY. THE ONLY REASON
CANNABIS WAS EVER ADDED TO
SCHEDULE ONE IN THE LATE
THIRTIES EARLY FORTIES WAS FOR
THE CRIMINALIZATION OF BLACK
AND BROWN PEOPLE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA I MEAN IN THIS
NATION. THERE WAS NO RUN ON OF
ABUSE OF CANNABIS WE HEARD OF
NO STORIES BUT WE UNDERSTOOD IT
GAVE LAW ENFORCEMENT EXTRA TO
CRIMINALIZE. BLACKAND BROWN
PEOPLE IN THE FIRST TWO PEOPLE
WHO WERE CONVICTED OF IT WORK
WHAT BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE IN
THIS COUNTRY SO THIS IS A
COMMON SENSE MEASURE. CANNABIS
IS A PLANT. AND THEN RE FOR WAS
EXPERIMENTING WITH HEMP AND
CANNABIS AS ALTERNATIVE FUELS
IN THE TWENTIES- WILLIAM
RANDOLPH HEARST'S FARMED THAT
PRODUCT. IN THE FORTIES IT'S A
COMMON SENSE MEASURES IS LONG
OVERDUE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE. ALL DEBATE HAVING
SAY MAY SO. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA I
ATKINS BY BATES. NO BELL I
FORGES NO BRADFORD HI CABALLERO
FIVE CHIANG. DALLY DODD I TO
RUSSELL I TELL JOHN. I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG AYE
HILL AYE HUESO. FIVE TADO.
JACKSON HI I JONES. LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE I MITCHELL I MONEY I
WARLOCK I MORALE. NO NIELSEN NO
PAN. PORTANTINO. FIVE ROTH IRA
I RUBIO. SKINNER I STERN HI I'M
BURKE. WHY KOWSKI AYE WIENER I
WILK HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME. CHANGE
DALLY. GROWTH TADO. JONES. PAN
I RUBIO FIVE AMBERG. ALL EYES
TWENTY NINE KNOWS FOR THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. MOVING
ON NOW. TO FILE ITEM SEVEN.
SENATOR LEYVA COLLEAGUES IF WE
COULD HAVE YOUR ATTENTION MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
RESOLUTION SIXTY SIX BY SENATOR
LEYVA RELATIVE TO REFLECT
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH. COLLEAGUES
IF WE COULD HAVE YOUR ATTENTION
SENATOR LABOR THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS SUCH AS
CHAIR OF THE LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT SENATE RESOLUTION SIXTY
SIX SR SIXTY SIX COMMEMORATES
THE FORTY SEVENTH ANNIVERSARY
OF THE NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE
ROE V. WADE DECISION WHICH
AFFIRM THAT EVERY WOMAN HAS THE
RIGHT TO CONTROL HER OWN
REPRODUCTIVE DECISIONS. THE
ABILITY OF A WILL TO DECIDE FOR
HERSELF WHEN IF AND WITH WHOM
SHE WANTS TO HAVE CHILDREN HAS
BEEN A CORNERSTONE OF WOMEN'S
EQUALITY THE ABILITY FOR WOMEN
TO CONTROL THE REPRODUCTIVE
DECISIONS HAS ALLOWED THEM TO
FULLY PARTICIPATE IN SOCIETY
AND IN AN ENABLED WOMEN TO MAKE
GREAT STRIDES POLITICALLY
SOCIALLY AND ECONOMICALLY. THE
NINE WOMEN ACCESS TO LEGAL
ABORTIONS DOES NOT PREVENT THEM
FROM HAVING AN ABORTION IT JUST
INCREASES THE LIKELIHOOD THAT
THEY WILL RESORT TO AN ILLEGAL
ABORTION UNDER UNSAFE
CONDITIONS PUT ANOTHER WAY. IN
ABORTION MEANS MORE WILL DIE
RUBY WAY THIS POTENTIAL IN JEFF
OF BEING OVERTURNED. THIS YEAR.
IN FUTURE YEARS JUNE MEDICAL
SERVICES L. L. C. VERSES DE IS
PENDING IN THE UNITED STATES
SUPREME COURT THIS CASE MAY
STRIP THE CONSTITUTIONAL
PROTECTIONS THAT SO MANY WOMEN
RELY ON. LET'S BE CLEAR NONE OF
THESE FIGHTS ARE NEW WHICH IS
WHY CALIFORNIA MUST STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ROE V. WADE
SR SIXTY SIX RESOLVES THE
CALIFORNIA REMAINS COMMITTED.
TO PROTECTING AND ADVANCING
ACCESS TO REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE NOW AND IN THE FUTURE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER LEYVA
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SENATOR
GONZALEZ. YES I JUST WANTED TO
SMALL THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
AND I WANT TO RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT AS A MEMBER OF THE
WOMEN'S LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS AND
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM CHINO
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD- BUT
NOW MORE THAN EVER WE SHOULD BE
SUPPORTIVE OF ROE V. WADE
ESPECIALLY AS WOMEN ARE IN
SERIOUS JEOPARDY OF BEING-
OPPRESSED AND WE KNOW THE-
ESPECIALLY WOMEN OF COLOR ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED.
AND WILL BEAR THE BRUNT OF A
LOT OF THE SUPPRESSION AND
CONSEQUENCES OF THE OVERTURN OF
ROE V. WADE SHOULD THAT HAPPEN
WE ALSO KNOW THAT AN AMICUS
BRIEF SIGNED BY MOSTLY MALE
LEGISLATORS OVER ONE HUNDRED
MAIL LEGISLATORS- INQUIRED TO
THE SUPREME COURT ABOUT THE
OVERTURNING OF THIS IMPORTANT
DECISION WHEN IT REALLY SHOULD
BE THE WOMAN'S RIGHT TO CHOOSE.
AND LACK OF ACCESS LACK OF
EDUCATIONAL REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
THE FEDERAL CUTS- TOWARDS
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH ISSUES WE
KNOW OUR ACCUMULATING AT THE
LOOK AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL SO WE
MUST DO EVERYTHING IN OUR POWER
HERE IN THE STATE TO INSURE
THAT WESAFEGUARD THIS
PROTECTION. THANK YOU AGAIN.
THANK YOU SO PAM. THANK YOU MAY
PRESIDENT SAN I TO ABOUT THE
STAND WITH MY GOOD FRIEND FROM
CHINO AND WITH THE WOMEN'S LACE
EIGHT CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF-
THIS FOR IMPORT RESOLUTION
COMMEMORATING THE FORTY SEVENTH
ANNIVERSARY OF ROE VERSUS. WADE
AS VICE CHAIR OF THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS WE DO STAND IN
SOLIDARITY WITH THE WOMEN'S
LESS SAFE CAUCUS AND PROTECTING
A WOMAN'S RIGHT TO CHOOSE.
CERTAINLY AS A PHYSICIAN AND
DOES ELECTED OFFICIAL I'M PROUD
TO BE REAFFIRMING Y STEADFAST
SUPPORT FOR THIS HISTORIC FAR
REACHING US SUPREME COURT
RULING IN FAVOR OF A WOMAN'S
RIGHT TO CHOOSE. THAT WOULD
MAKE NOTE THAT ALSO- MY
PHYSICIAN COLLEAGUES AND MANY
OF THE- ORGANIZATIONS- JOIN ME
AND SAYING SUPPORT OF A WOMAN'S
RIGHT TO CHOOSE AND MAKING SURE
THAT DECISION IS BETWEEN. A
WOMAN AND HER PHYSICIAN AND
THAT SHOULD NOT BE A DECISION
THAT'S IMPOSED BY THE
GOVERNMENT. AS I THIS WEEKEND I
ATTENDED AND JOINED IN THE
WOMEN'S MARCH- THIS PAST
WEEKEND ALONG WITH MANY AMAZING
WOMEN LEADERS HERE IN SAC OUR
REGION I'M CONTINUES REMINDED
THE IMPORTANCE OF BEING SURE WE
AMPLIFY WOMEN'S VOICES.
CERTAINLY IN SOMETHING AS
CRITICAL AS REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS
AS WELL AS IN ALL ARENAS SO
TOGETHER WE ARE STRONG AND
TOGETHER WE WILL FIGHT AND
PROTECT. THE RIGHT TO CHOOSE
AND REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM FOR
ALL WOMEN HERE INSTEAD. OF
CALIFORNIA COUNTRY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR PAN SO MITCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MATT PRESIDENT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU KNOW
COLLEAGUES A TO STUDY THE SAN
FOR STUDIES IF ROE V. WADE WERE
WEEKENDER OVERTURNED THE RIGHT
TO CHOOSE WILL BE IMMEDIATELY
PROHIBITED IN TWENTY FOUR
STATES. AND IN FIVE OTHER
STATES PEOPLE WILL LOSE ACCESS
TO LEGAL PROTECTIONS HIT THEY
GET AN ABORTION FOR ALL OF US
WHO HAVE WATCHED THE DYSTOPIAN
WORLD OF THE HANDMAID'S TALE
COME TO LIFE ACROSS STATES LIKE
ALABAMA GEORGIA MISSOURI IN
OTHER STATES IT'S VERY CLEAR
THAT WE MUST CONTINUE TO BE THE
RESISTANCE FOR A FIGHT THAT
APPARENTLY NEVER TRULY WAS
FINISHED I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL SENATOR SKINNER. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I MEMBERS-
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION AND I IN LISTENING
TO THE COMMENTS SO FAR WAS
SITTING THERE THINKING TO
MYSELF. I HAVE TO ADMIT I'M I'M
NINETY. BECAUSE I HAVE CONTINUE
TO GO ALONG FROM BACK FROM YOU
pKNOW BOTH CHILDHOOD MY HIGH
SCHOOL DAYS COLLEGE DAYS AS AS
I. BROUGH INTO VARIOUS
PROFESSIONS THINKING THAT
CERTAIN THINGS CERTAIN RIGHTS
THAT WE ACHIEVED WE'RE JUST
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO GO
BACKWARDS WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT HIM. SO I THINK
ABOUT FOR EXAMPLE HI I REMEMBER
BEING LAUDED BECAUSE BACK IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO I WAS THE
FIRST GIRL ELECTED TO MY
STUDENT BODY PRESIDENCY MY HIGH
SCHOOL AND THEN SHORTLY
THEREAFTER NOT VERY MANY YEARS
AFTER WE HAD WOMEN ASTRONAUTS
WE HAD A WOMAN ON THE SUPREME
COURT SO I JUST FIGURED OKAY
WHAT BY THE TIME I WAS THE AGE
I AM NOW WE NEVER HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT ANYMORE WOMEN'S FIRST
BECAUSE- THERE'D BE WOMEN IN
LEADERSHIP POSITIONS IN. READ
NUMBERS ALL. THE IN EVERY. NOT
SO. THEN OF COURSE RIGHTS I
WATCHED AS A CHILD. CREDIBLE
EFFORT TO RE SECURE VOTING
RIGHTS THAT WERE GRANTED AFTER
THE CIVIL WAR AND- I WATCH THE
VIOLENCE THAT ENSUED AND OF
COURSE THIS WEEKEND I WEN TO
THE MARTIN LUTHER KING EVENTS
AND THIS WAS THAT CONTINUED BY
AND OF COURSE THE HONORING OF
DR MARTIN LUTHER KING WAS NOT
JUST A MATTER OF THE VICTORY OF
VOTING RIGHTS BUT SO MANY OTHER
THINGS TO SEVERAL CIVIL RIGHTS
THAT WE NOW SEE BEING REVERSED.
BUT WITH VOTING RIGHTS WE ARE
SEEING COUNTIES AND STATES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY STRIPPING
THOUSANDS OF VOTERS FROM THE
ROLLS SO WE'RE HAVING TO RE
FIGHT ALL OF THAT AND THEN HERE
AGAIN I'M A FRESHMAN IN COLLEGE
WHEN ROE VERSUS WADE. IS
SETTLED. A YOU KNOW INITIALLY
YOU I KNEW THAT IT WAS TO BE
JUST THE ONE CORD CASE WAS
KNOCKING TO BE ENOUGH BUT THEN
SAW TO PRO. ATTITUDES CHANGE
OUR STATE ACT IN MUCH MORE UP
THROW. PRO ABORTION I WANT TO
ISSUES CHOI. AND YET NOW IN THE
WAY TWENTY YEARS WE'VE SEEN
THIS INCREDIBLE. ORGANIZED
AFFECTIVE ONSLAUGHT AGAINST MY
RIGHTS MY DAUGHTER'S RIGHT AN
ALL WOMEN'S RIGHTS TO. HAVE
AUTHORITY OVER THERE
REPRODUCTIVE LIFE'S. NUMBER
WONDERING WHAT IS THINGS ARE WE
GOING TO SEE A ROAD SO I STAND
HERE VERY STRONGLY IN SUPPORT I
ASK EVERYONE TO JOIN IN THE
SUPPORT LET US STOP CORRODING
THESE RIGHTS THAT WE HAVE
FOUGHT SO HARD FOR. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR SKINNER ANY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SENATOR WINNER. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE RESOLUTION AND
IN SUPPORT OF ROE V. WADE- ROE
V. WADE IS SO CENTRAL TO OUR
AMERICAN CONSTITUTIONAL SYSTEM-
WHICH STAND FOR THE BASIC
PROPOSITION THAT PEOPLE- IN
THIS SOCIETY GET TO MAKE
DECISIONS ABOUT THEIR OWN LIVES
INSTEAD OF HAVING OTHER PEOPLE
MAKE THOSE DECISIONS FOR THEM-
AND I WAS SAYS AS A GAY MAN
WERE AND OUR COMMUNITY WE'VE
BEEN TOLD FOR MANY YEARS WHAT
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO DO OR NOT DO
WITH OUR BODIES. AS NONE OF
ANYONE'S BUSINESS WHAT WE ARE
USING FOR OUR OWN LIVES AND THE
FACT THAT ANYONE WOULD TELL A
WOMAN YOU MUST CARRY A
PREGNANCY TO TERM I DON'T CARE
WHAT YOU WONDER WHY YOUR
SITUATION IS OR WHETHER IT
MAKES SENSE FOR YOU TO HAVE A
CHILD RIGHT NOW OR WHAT YOUR
DOCTOR IS ADVISING YOU. IT'S A
THAT WE'RE GONNA SAYS TELL YOU
THAT ARE GOING TO BE FOR FORCED
TO CARRY THAT BE TO TERM YOU'RE
GOING TO BE FORCED. TO GIVE
BIRTH TO THAT CHILD BY THAT DIE
IS TO SO NONSENSICAL. AND THE
OFFICER OF WHAT. ANYONE WOULD
ADVOCATE FOR IN A FREE SOCIETY
AND YOU KNOW WE MUST FIGHT TO
PROTECT ROW WE HAVE- A VERY
DANGEROUS APPEAL- IN THE US
SUPREME COURT NOW JUNE MEDICAL
SERVICES VERSUS KEY. THAT IF
THE SUPREME COURT UPHOLDS THAT.
LAW IN LOUISIANA IN LOUISIANA
THERE WILL BE ZERO LOCATIONS IN
THE STATE OF LOUISIANA WHERE A
WOMAN CAN ACCESS ABORTION
SERVICES AND WE WILL SEE THIS
SPREAD AS WE ALREADY ARE. LIKE
WILDFIRE ACROSS STATE WERE
MOSTLY MEN. ARE DIRECTING WOMEN
THAT THEY MUST GIVE BIRTH AND
THEY CAN'T OF ACCESS TO THESE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH SERVICES-
WE KNOW THAT THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC SUPPORTS A RIGHT TO
CHOOSE- AND WE MUST PROTECT
ROW. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SING IN
HEARING NONE SENATOR LEYVA YOU
MAY CLOSE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU TO ALL OF
MY COLLEAGUES WHO SET UP IN
SUPPORT- I DO WANT TO SAY TO
THE SENATOR FROM OAKLAND I TOO
WAS A LITTLE NAIVE WHEN I CAME
HERE TO SACRAMENTO SIX YEARS
AGO- AND REALIZE. THAT A
WOMAN'S RIGHT TO CHOOSE IS
STILL UNDER ATTACK I AM SHOCKED
THAT I'M FIFTY TWO YEARS OLD
AND IT'S STILL AN ISSUE BUT YOU
KNOW WHAT WE WILL CONTINUE TO
FIGHT WILL CONTINUE MAKE SURE
ALL WOMEN HAVE ACCESS. TO
CHOICE AND ACCESS TO MAKING
DECISIONS AND THEIR OWN BODY
AND WE DO KNOW THAT 70% PLUS OF
AMERICA'S AMERICAN SUPPORT A
WOMAN'S RIGHT TO CHOOSE SO WE
CANNOT LET A MINORITY DICTATE
WHAT A WOMAN CAN DO WITH HER
OWN BODY. I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. ALL DEBATE HAVING
CEASE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA. I ATKINS. AYE BATES.
NO WELL. I FORGES. NO BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO. I CHIANG. DALLY NO
DODD. I DORADO I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG AYE
HILL AYE HUESO FIVE TIGHTEN
FIVE JACKSON FIVE JONES NO
LEYVA I MCGUIRE FIVE MITCHELL.
FIVE MONEY I MORE LOCK NO
MORALE NO NIELSEN NO PAN I
PORTS AND- FIVE ROTH I RUBIO
FIVE SKINNER. I STERN HI NUMBER
HI MY CASKEY. EIGHT THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
COLLEAGUES WE ARE NOW GOING TO
MOVE TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IT
WOULD ANYONE OBJECT TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ASSN AN ITEM
BE REMOVED. SEEING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ITEM
ELEVEN AND TWELVE. ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE A ONE
AND SENATE BILL SEVEN TWENTY
THREE. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO THE CHANNEL THINK WE GOT A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL SO LET'S GO
AHEAD AND CALL THE CONSENT
CALENDAR MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE- ROLL. ALLEN HI FI
ARCHULETA FIVE ATKINS FIVE
BATES AYE BELL FIVE FOR JUST.
FIVE BRADFORD HI CABALLERO I
CHIANG. DOLLY I DODD. FIVE
THERE ARE SO I GALGIANI I
GLAZER. FIVE GONZALEZ FIVE
GROSS. HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE
HUESO FIVE TADO FIVE JACKSON I
JONES I LEYVA I MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL AYE MONNING. I WARLOCK
I MARROW I NIELSEN. I PAN AYE
PORTANTINO FIVE ROTH AYE RUBIO.
I SKINNER I STERN. I AM BURKE I
LIKE HOW SKI. HI WIENER AYE
WILK HI. BUYS THIRTY SEVEN NO
ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED THAT CONCLUDES OUR
ITEMS ON THE DAILY FILE WE WILL
RETURN NOW TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS COLLEGE THIS IS THE
TIME OF FOR A JOURNEY IN MEMORY
MOTIONS ARE THERE ANY CHURN IN
MEMORY MOTIONS SENATOR WIENER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT ARE
COLLEAGUES- TO GREAT SADNESS
THAT I RISE TO US THAT WE HAD
DURING A MEMORY OF TERENCE
HALLINAN. WHO SERVED AS A
DISTRICT ATTORNEY OF SAN
FRANCISCO FROM NINETEEN NINETY
SIX TO TWO THOUSAND FOUR- HE
WAS A LIFELONG FIGHTER FOR
CIVIL RIGHTS AND FOR PEOPLE WHO
RIDE THEIR VOICES- A GREAT
LEADER IN OUR CITY- HE PASSED
AWAY ON FRIDAY. PEACEFULLY IN
HIS SLEEP AT THE AGE OF EIGHTY
THREE- TERENCE FOUGHT AGAINST
INJUSTICE HIS ENTIRE LIFE- BACK
TO THE NINETEEN SIXTIES WHEN HE
WAS ARRESTED IN D. AND AS PART
OF ANTI WAR PROTESTS AND IN
CIVIL RIGHTS DEMONSTRATIONS. HE
GAINED THE NICKNAME KO- BASED
ON HIS PROWESS AS A BOXER WHO
ALMOST MADE THE U. S. OLYMPIC
TEAM. HE ATTENDED UC BERKELEY
THE LONDON SCHOOL OF ECONOMICS.
AND IN NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE YOU
GRADUATED FROM UC HASTINGS
SCHOOL OF LAW. HE AFTER- A LONG
TIME IN POLITICS AND ACTIVISM
HE WAS ELECTED TO THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. WERE HE SERVED
FROM NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT TO
NINETY FIVE HE WAS AN EARLY
SUPPORTER OF THE RIGHTS OF
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE- AND OF
DECRIMINALIZING PROSTITUTION. I
DURING HIS TENURE AS DISTRICT
ATTORNEY- HE WAS REALLY AN
EARLY ADOPTER OF APPROACHES- TO
AVOID INCARCERATION
PARTICULARLY AMONG JUVENILES-
AND TO MAKE SURE WE'RE FOCUSING
ON REHABILITATION- AS DISTRICT
ATTORNEY HE REALLY PRIORITIZE
AND DRAMATICALLY INCREASED THE
HIRING. OF WOMEN PEOPLE OF
COLOR IN LGBT PEOPLE. IN THE
SAN FRANCISCO DA'S OFFICE. ON
CURRENT WITH THE BILL. OFFICERS
JUSTICE HE WAS TOUGH- HE WAS
WILLING TO RUFFLE FEATHERS- AND
HIS DEATH IS A LOSS FOR THE
CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. OTHER WE
ADJOURN HIS MEMORY THANK YOU
SENATOR WINNER AND PLEASE MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE HIS NAME
BROUGHT FORWARD SO WE CAN
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZE HIM AND
HIS. OUTSTANDING SERVICE TO THE
PEOPLE OF SAN FRANCISCO. ARE
THERE ANY FURTHER. A JOURNEY IN
MEMORY SEEING NONE. AND IF
THERE IS NO OTHER BUSINESS.
SENATOR ATKINS THE DESK IS
CLEAR THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
AND I WOULD. JUST SAY OUR NEXT
FLOOR SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
THIS THURSDAY JANUARY TWENTY
THIRD TWENTY TWENTY AT NINE AM
THANK YOU THANK YOU MAYOR PO
TEM THE SENATE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY PM AT
WHICH TIME THE ADJOURNMENT
MOTION WILL BE MADE. WE
RECONVENE THIS THURSDAY AT NINE
AM.